do you expect that if we can't find a
diplomatic solution
to ukraine the ukraine problem that
russia will either invade and occupy
or install a puppet government
well first of all the number one
priority is deterring vladimir putin
from taking that action that's why we
are offering to deploy
extra troops into estonia
we are providing more air support across
the black sea and we're supplying
defensive weapons to ukraine to make
sure that they are in the best possible
position
should vladimir putin try to stage an
incursion what i'll be announcing later
this week
is improved legislation on sanctions so
we can target more russian interests
that are of direct relevance to the
kremlin because we absolutely need to
stop this happening that is our number
one priority
of course we'll use diplomacy i'm
traveling to ukraine this week i'll be
traveling to moscow next week
however the number one thing that will
stop vladimir putin taking action is if
he understands the cost of that action
this could result in a quagmire and he
should be well aware of that well let's
take those steps one by one first the
military and then the economic um
i'm no defensive expert but a defense
expert but any armed conflict is going
to be in ukraine
um
and we already have a small number of
personnel there why are we sending
troops to estonia
well we already have troops in estonia
the enhanced forward presence as part of
nato and what this is about is
bolstering our allies in the baltics
they feel increasingly under threat with
russia's uh
aggressive behavior on the borders
through belarus but also uh directly
with the baltics so we are supplying
further uh further troops as are our
nato allies we're also strengthening uh
around the black sea as well so this is
about making sure that we bolster our
nato our nato allies who we have direct
commitments to as well as supplying
those defensive weapons into ukraine to
make it much harder
for the russians to think it's an easy
target yeah but um
the total in estonia will be 1800 troops
now
putin has 100 000 on the ukraine border
that force in estonia is a pretty small
bolster isn't it i mean he's not going
to take that seriously
this is part of a work with nato overall
so
our american our canadian our french
allies are all putting
further further forces to strengthen
nato's eastern eastern flank and that's
that's important
and the point i would make about
the threat from uh vladimir putin is
it's on the border of ukraine
the ukrainians will fight hard they are
not going to give up easily and this
could well result into a quagmire you
know like the like the russians saw
in afghanistan or chechner so this is
not going to be
simple
for russia
we need to make sure that that's the
case well well let's think about how the
quagmire as you put it gets created
will
we as a country
support a ukraine resistance force if
they are invaded will we send them money
will we send them weapons does vladimir
putin need to know
that we may not put boots on the ground
but we will supply and support and fund
a resistance movement that will make
life difficult for him for years
we're ruling absolutely nothing out so
we're already supporting in areas like
cyber
in areas like intelligence so recently
we released intelligence that showed
that vladimir putin was seeking to
install a puppet government in kiev
we're working on other areas of support
i mentioned the defensive weapons we've
trained up 20 000 ukrainian troops so we
will we will look at every
every option and we will work with our
nato allies to support the ukrainians
and support freedom and democracy and
that includes
providing money and arms to make
any russian occupation of ukraine as
difficult and frankly impossible as
chechnya was for russia we are already
supplying defensive weapons to the
ukrainians and we are supplying uh
training and the skills that they need
to be able to resist any russian
invasion all right let's talk about the
economic sanctions i noticed that you
you said that you plan to bring in new
legislation um
as far as i understood it we thought we
had the powers to be able to do what was
necessary what what will be new about
the economic sanctions beyond the
you know
magnitude sanctions that have been
applied before what what do you what
have you got so currently the economic
sanctions are
fairly narrowly drawn
so we could only target companies with a
direct involvement in destabilizing
ukraine
what we are looking to do is widen that
so any company of interest to
the kremlin
and the regime in russia would be able
to be targeted so there will be nowhere
to hide for
putin's oligarchs
for
russian companies involved in propping
up the russian state that's what we are
looking at doing this week would that
include for example
the capacity to seize property which may
not be
very far from where we're sitting here
which is worth
hundreds of millions of pounds in the
hands of uh putin's oligarch pals who
put their money into london property
nothing is off the table and we're not
going to go into details of exactly who
and how we would target the sanctions
what the legislation enables us to do is
hit a much wider variety of targets so
there can be nobody who thinks that they
will be immune to those sanctions so the
message to mr putin and his friends is
where have you got the money where have
you stashed it we're coming after it
absolutely and we are working very
closely with our allies including the us
including the europeans to make sure
that that is a
severe package of sanctions so the
russian government understand that they
will be hard hit in the event of an
incursion this is going to be very very
difficult for russia and we are working
on deterrence at the same time as
diplomacy persuading russia to
desist from
amassing troops on the border persuading
them to move backwards i don't want to
seem obsessed with the property other
people's property but
you know we've said a lot of this before
after the sales poisoning for example
and so on um and it seems that we
haven't really done very much to hurt
the people who have got all those big
houses in in belgravia or who have large
deposits in london
banks is the problem here that in truth
you might say you want to do this but
the cost of it to this country
is dramatic for every uh russian
oligarch whose accounts are frozen that
means that somebody isn't going to get
investment from that russian money in
this country for example to support the
leveling up
agenda is that the problem that it's
going to cost us to do this
we have seized over a billion pounds
worth of assets and we have put
sanctions in place on specific
individuals but what i'm saying trevor
is we want to do more vouchers we want
to do more and that is why we are
legislating to broaden our sanctions and
fundamentally
the most important thing is defending
freedom and democracy and that is more
important
than immediate financial issues and that
is true not just the united kingdom but
also for our friends in germany who are
now taking a much tougher line on
nordstrom 2. you know we cannot
favor short-term economic interests over
the long-term
survival of freedom and democracy in
europe
that's the tough decision all of us have
got to make okay if it's that important
are you going to tell the germans it's
time to cancel nordstrom 2. yes well the
germans olaf schultz has said
that it'd be very difficult for
nordstrom 2 to go ahead in the event of
a russian incursion so we have seen a
toughening of the germans position on
that i had a good call this week with
the german foreign minister
and we're and we're supporting that we
absolutely
if there's an invasion nordstrom 2 stops
completely and
one of the issues we have
is european dependence on russian gas
in the same way as we're seeing economic
dependence grow on china and we're
seeing increased use of economic
coercion by china we are seeing russia
use the fact that it is supplying gas to
much of europe as an economic tool and
we cannot allow that to happen and we're
aligned with the germans on that we're
aligned with the americans on that all
right can we go on to the second of your
three job you're such a busy cabinet
minister which is uh brexit um
elections in northern ireland within 100
days the uh democratic unionists are
desperate for either for a settlement of
the protocol
or the trigger triggering of article 16.
just to get clear first of all
do you have a date in your mind at which
you'd simply stop the clock and invoke
article 16 if there is no agreement on
the protocol how long are you going to
allow these negotiations to go on
the protocol isn't working i was in
northern ireland
earlier this week looking at what was
happening on the ground and people are
struggling to import
food and other products from great
britain and that can't be right because
we are a single country we're a single
market and people should be able to get
those goods uh and products from gb into
northern ireland so i want to fix the
protocol i think there is a deal to be
done we've had positive discussions uh
with the european union everyone
recognizes as a problem and my priority
is protecting peace and stability in
northern ireland protecting the belfast
good friday agreement so i think and we
are in intensive talk so i saw marilyn
cech on
monday in brussels he's coming over uh
this week on thursday for further talks
and in answer your question trevor you
know we need to make progress urgently
on this uh we've got a joint council
uh
dates date the 21st of february and i
want to see
significant progress by then oh so
trader first of february if it's not
happening then article 16 swims back
into view
well we always retain
the ability to use a safeguard if we
have to
i think by far the better option is to
make progress with the eu
to get a deal to get those goods flowing
because that's what the people of
northern ireland want they want to be
treated as part of the uk they want to
be able to access you know the parcels
they want their pets to be able to
travel freely you know they want to be
able to
get those products in from gb
but yes if we don't make sufficient
progress we will have to consider using
the safeguard mechanism which is
provided for in the northern ireland
protocol i mean that's what the
safeguard mechanism is therefore all
right let's let's uh let's come back to
i think the thing that will be
concerning most people
in most of the country today
in 60 days time every working person is
going to be hit with a national
insurance contribution
increase of 1.25 percent that's 10 rise
for most people
in practical terms the average household
that is something like 300 pounds a year
or according to the office of national
statistics uh six weeks shopping at
supermarket that's going to be followed
we think by an energy price rise that's
another 600 quid that's uh
another 12 weeks shopping for poorer
households a lot more now
assuming you don't want
most of the country to spend
a third of the year not eating where is
where are people going to find that
money from
it is a very difficult situation
that that we face and that is faced
around the globe on the cost of living
because we are seeing the
backwashes of the coveted crisis we've
seen problems with supply chains problem
with the with the delivery of goods the
best thing we can do as a government
which is what the prime minister is
doing is opening up our economy helping
the economy to grow that's why we've now
got the fastest growing economy in the
g7 we're one of the most open countries
where people are able to get back to
work we're able to get the economy going
and ultimately
we are going to pay the cost that we
generated during the covid crisis
by economic growth and that's what the
chancellor's focused on that's what the
prime minister's focus on but of course
you know we do have to pay
for the money we spent supporting
businesses and supporting people during
the covered crisis it's not it's not an
easy situation to deal with but i think
the public recognize the public do
recognize that we now have higher
employment than we had at the start of
the cavity crisis and that really is a
achievement but we are talking about
people in work and i i've got to say
this this is quite baffling coming from
your government and particularly from a
co-author of a pamphlet which extolled
the verse to the virtues of free market
and low taxes uh the revolution wrought
by mrs thatch and this morning prime
minister and chancellor boast that their
thatcher rights um now of course you had
to deal with covid but margaret thatcher
had to deal with a war she had to deal
with riots and regeneration of the inner
cities she had to deal with double-digit
inflation throughout the 1980s she did
not
impose new taxes
this is not conservatism as you have
always told us it should be
we want to see taxes come down and the
prime minister and the chancellor made
that very very clear you've just
increased them to the highest
level uh a burden since actually several
decades the the issue is we need to get
economic growth up and we've already
made a good start by being one of the
first countries to
implement the vaccine program the
booster program open up our economy
we're now looking at what more we can do
in terms of freedoms that we can
exercise now that we've left the
european union for example making our
regulatory system better unleashing our
financial services industries but those
things take time and i think the public
appreciates that we spent a lot of money
during cave and we need we do need to
pay that money back you must understand
why i'm puzzled
you're saying
we've got to raise taxes and we're going
to rely on growth that's what the labour
people come in and say this is not what
i expect from you liz truss
what i'm saying is that we've had to
take difficult decisions because of the
extraordinary circumstances we face
we are committed to cutting taxes we are
committed to driving up grace we are
committed to using our new regulatory
freedom all right okay look i mean
we could talk economics all morning but
let's frankly let's deal with the
politics of where we are at the moment
we talked about some very serious issues
ukraine energy prices and all the rest
of it but the truth is there's no space
in politics right now uh
for the most part the political classes
and most of the country are thinking
frankly are waiting for sue gray isn't
your
government really paralyzed by the fact
that you cannot get past the behavior
the conduct of some people
who uh in whitehall in number 10 and
indeed some of our leading
political
leaders uh this is a problem of your own
making isn't it and in particular the
prime minister's making i don't
recognize your characterization of the
situation it's a coach i i have been
spending my time administered
in brussels
northern ireland you know i'm going to
ukraine we are
working to supply more troops to
the borders of the baltics we are
working to
up our sanctions package we are 100
focused on our day job uh michael gove
is launching his new leveling up paper
uh we are working on the booster program
which has been incredibly successful he
loves those people
it was most people trevor
what they want to see is they want to
see
the economy they want to see their taxes
come down don't they
the way we're going to be able to do
that is by getting the economy going
that's the way to bring down taxes
all right look uh before before you go
there's an uh there's a i i imagine that
many of our viewers will want me to ask
you uh the obvious question you've been
asked several times you're the longest
serving member of the cabinet um you're
a very senior person
um
you know you've got these three jobs
that you've got to got to do
uh i'm not going to ask you the obvious
uh hypothetical question what happens
and so on but let me ask you this um
in the prime minister's own words
when it comes to number 10 downing
street the keys to number 10 downstream
he said if the ball comes loose at the
back of the scrum it would be a great
great thing to have a crack at do you
agree
well the prime minister is having no i
think that's all so before he was prime
minister i'm asking you if you agree
i'm 100 focused trevor on
delivering on the northern ireland
protocol
on our foreign policy which is
very important at the moment we're
one of the members of the permanent
security council the uk has a huge role
to play i can assure you that is taking
up all of my time and more